les femmes haïtiennes bien à la semaine
ou à chaque deux semaines pour
l'entretien de leurs extensions ou de
leurs cheveux naturels et j'imagine que
se passer de deux à trois heures par
semaine dans un salon de coiffure je
vais parler un peu policé oui vous
écoutez top modèle la leaf et au poids
politique j'aurais cru ça se ressemble
un peu en entrant j'avais
personnellement moi je suis une autre
engin et gaspille pas une mauvaise chose
la commission charbonneau regarder ça
fait longtemps les personnes respect est
à présent de sa très centré à lippi
d'argent dans les neuf races place gardé
les rues et rudy si c'est déplorable
tu achète une voiture au bout de 25 mois
six mois c'est la personne que tu as
battu elle a dû
six 6 essais de plus de garderies
publiques
je parle besoin parce que j'ai un enfant
donc les prix augmentent logement
désaccord merde moi c'est sûr ça va être
le pitch est quand même pour que le
québec devienne un pays je peux pas
blanc mais pauline marois d' pas
respecté ses engagements
parce que je me dis être ministre il ya
déjà distribué déjà des choses qui ont
été entamées avant même que l de booker
le débat politique
moi je veux bien géré il avait des beaux
yeux bleus sait sauf eux par exemple
marois avec qu'est ce qu'on va retenir
de ce 1 200 de son règne du fait
national à la charte des valeurs où est
ce que j'ai envie de retourner dans ce
genre de débats vide ya tellement
d'autres problèmes
j'ai en tout cas moi j'attends avec
l'achat de balancer comme pour masquer
les vrais problèmes
c'est comme pour faire diversion